hello um I'd like to introduce you to
someone
this is Johnny that's Johnny but spell
accidentally with an M in case you are
wondering because we're not all perfect
johnny is an alien who has been sent to
earth with a mission to study humans
johnny is feeling lost and alone and far
from home and I think we've all felt
this way or at least I have I wrote this
story about this alien at a moment in my
life when I was feeling particularly
alien I just moved to Cambridge and
started my doctoral program at MIT and I
was feeling intimidated and isolated and
very much like I didn't belong but I had
a lifeline of sorts see I was writing
jokes for years and years and sharing
them on social media and I found that I
was turning to doing this more and more
now for many people the internet can
feel like a lonely place it can feel
like this a big endless expansive void
where you can constantly call out to it
but no one's ever listening but I
actually found a comfort in speaking out
to the void I found in sharing my
feelings with the void eventually the
void started to speak back and it turns
out that the void isn't this endless
lonely expanse at all but instead it's
full of all sorts of other people also
staring out into it and also wanting to
be heard now there have been many bad
things that have come from social media
I'm not trying to dispute that at all to
be online at any given point is to feel
so much sadness and anger and violence
it can feel like the end of the world
yet at the same time I'm conflicted
because I can't deny the fact that so
many of my closest friends are people
that I had met originally online and I
think that's partly because there's this
confessional nature to social media it
can feel like you're writing in this
personal intimate diary that's
completely private
yet at the same time you want everyone
in the world to read it and I think part
of that I think the joy of that is that
we get to experience things from
perspectives from people who are
completely different
ourselves and sometimes that's a nice
thing for example when I first joined
Twitter I found that so many of the
people that I was following were talking
about mental health and going to therapy
in ways that had none of the stigma that
they often do when we talk about these
issues in person through them the
conversation around mental health was
normalized and they helped me realize
that going to therapy was something that
would help me as well now for many
people it sounds like a scary idea to be
talking about all these topics so
publicly and so openly on the Internet
I feel like a lot of people think that
it is a big scary thing to be online if
you're not already perfectly and fully
formed but I think the Internet can be
actually a great place to not know and I
think we can treat that with excitement
because to me there's something
important about sharing your
imperfections and your insecurities and
your vulnerabilities with other people
now when someone shares that they feel
sad or afraid or alone for example it
actually makes me feel less alone not by
getting rid of any of my loneliness but
by showing me that I am not alone in
feeling lonely and as a writer and as an
artist I care very much about making
this comfort of being vulnerable a
communal thing something that we can
share with each other I'm excited about
externalizing the internal about taking
those invisible personal feelings that I
don't have words for holding them to the
light putting words to them and then
sharing them with other people in the
hopes that it might help them find words
to find their feelings as well now I
know that sounds like a big thing but
ultimately I'm interested in putting all
these things into small approachable
packages because when we can hide them
into these smaller pieces I think
they're easier to approach I think
they're more fun I think they can more
easily help us see our shared human as'
sometimes that takes the form of a short
story sometimes that takes the form of a
cute book of illustrations for example
and sometimes that takes the form of a
silly joke that I'll throw on the
internet for example a few months ago I
posted this app idea for a dog walking
service where a
shows up at your door and you have to
get out of the house and go for a walk
if there are app developers in the
audience please find me after the talk
or I'd like to share every time I feel
anxious about sending an email when I
sign my emails best
it's short for I am trying my best which
is short for please don't hate me I
promise I'm trying my best or my answer
to the classic icebreaker if I could
have dinner with anyone dead or alive I
would I am very lonely and I find that
when I post things like these online the
reaction is very similar people come
together to share a laugh to share in
that feeling and then to disperse just
as quickly but yes leaving me once again
alone but I think sometimes these little
gatherings can be quite meaningful for
example when I graduated from
architecture school and I moved to
Cambridge I posted this question how
many people in your life have you
already had your last conversation with
and I was thinking about my own friends
who had moved away to different cities
in different countries even and how hard
it would be for me to keep in touch with
them but other people started replying
and sharing their own experiences
somebody talked about a family member
they had a falling out with someone
talked about a loved one who had passed
away quickly and unexpectedly someone
else talked about their friends from
school who had moved away as well but
then something really nice started
happening instead of just replying to me
people started replying to each other
and they started to talk to each other
and share their own experiences and
comfort each other and encourage each
other to reach out to that friend that
they haven't spoken to in a while or
that family member that they had a
falling-out with and eventually we got
this little tiny micro community it felt
like this support group formed of all
sorts of people coming together and I
think every time we post online every
time we do this there's a chance that
these little micro communities can form
there's a chance that all sorts of
different creatures can come together
and be drawn together and sometimes
the month of the Internet you get to
find a kindred spirit
sometimes that's in the reading the
replies and the comment sections and
finding a reply that is particularly
kind or insightful or funny sometimes
that's in going to follow someone and
seeing that they already follow you back
and sometimes that's in looking at
someone that you know in real life and
seeing the things that you write and the
things that they write and realizing
that you share so many of the same
interests as they do and that brings
them closer together to you sometimes if
you're lucky you get to meet another
alien but I am worried too
because as we all know the internet for
the most part doesn't feel like this we
all know that for the most part the
internet feels like a place where we
misunderstand each other where we come
into conflict with each other
where there's all sorts of confusion and
screaming and yelling and shouting and
it feels like there's too much of
everything it feels like chaos and I
don't know how to square away the bad
parts with the good because as we know
and as we've seen the bad parts can
really really hurt us it feels to me
that the platforms that we use to
inhabit these online spaces have been
designed either ignorant ly or willfully
to allow for harassment and abuse to
propagate misinformation to enable
hatred and hate speech and the violence
that comes from it and it feels like
none of our current platforms are doing
enough to address and to fix that but
still and maybe probably unfortunately
I'm still drawn to these online spaces
as many others are because sometimes it
just feels like that's where all the
people are and I feel silly and stupid
sometimes for valuing these small
moments of human connection in times
like these but I've always operated
under this idea that these little
moments of humaneness are not
superfluous they're not retreats from
the world at all but instead they're the
reasons why we come to these spaces they
are important and vital and they affirm
and they give us life
and they are these tiny temporary
sanctuaries that show us that we are not
as alone as we think we are and so yes
even though life is bad and everyone's
sad and one day we're all going to die
I think the inflatable metaphorical
bouncy castle in this case is really our
relationships and our connections to
other people and so one night when I was
feeling particularly sad and hopeless
about the world I shouted out to the
void to the lonely darkness I said at
this point logging onto social media
feels like holding someone's hand at the
end of the world and this time instead
of the void responding it was people who
showed up who started replying to me and
then who started talking to each other
and slowly this little tiny community
formed everybody came together to hold
hands and in these dangerous and on
short times in the midst of it all I
think the thing that we have to hold on
to is other people and I know that is a
small thing made up of small moments but
I think it is one tiny tiny sliver of
light in all the darkness thank you
thank you